[musique]
[applaudissements]
sous éteindre la tourbière doit être transportée
bien mélanger avec de l'eau jusqu'à ce
état de pâte liquide sans grumeaux nous
nous l'appelons et quand ce sera uniformément
mélangé alors ça s'éteindra
parce que si vous le remplissez simplement d'eau et
laisser l'eau va s'évaporer la tourbière va geler
d'abord tu y resteras sous
film de combustion de coke durera et ensuite
quand l'eau s'évapore elle ressort
la surface va commencer à brûler donc
assurez-vous de mélanger avec des pelles
l'eau à l'état liquide maintenant ils
il suffit de renverser de l'eau creuser dedans
les pelles sont mélangées dans cet état
dont nous avons besoin et un peu plus tard nous
passons en revue le maître vidéo masha polypro
nous mesurons la température et nous nous assurons que shkolota
enivre exactement autour des températures devraient
être inférieur à 40 degrés si vous êtes plus grand
nous reviendrons seront au même endroit
travail
[musique]
il y a dix ans personne mais sérieux
m'écouterait si je parlais
ce qui est en Sibérie et allez dans le secteur des prix
le sujet de la physique est la Russie centrale
c'est le nord-ouest, ils l'ont extrait là-bas, mais pas
maintenant mon ragoût leur sibérie et
se préparer de ces autres pays et ce
tout ici est la sécheresse du feu est tout une conséquence
changement climatique sur les brûlures encore et
causes du changement climatique parce que
chaque mètre carré donc pain d'épice
des gaz à effet de serre sont émis
plus que d'un feu de forêt à une telle étape
quand cette bombe climatique droite
[musique]
[applaudissements]